Jake:哎
Jake: Hey
Shure: 对我给你们
Alice:对嗯你把那个链接导
Alice: Yeah, you just need to import that link
Jake:呃就是在群里修硕发了一个来搞一搞
Jake: Uh, Shure posted something in the group, let's go check it out
其他人：你微信一直在弹消息你不要看一下吗
Others: Your WeChat keeps popping up messages, don't you want to check it?
Jake:你帮我看一下
Jake: Help me check it
Jake:哎呦
Jake: Oh no
Jake:允许粘贴加一个
Jake: Allow paste and add one more
Tasha: 其实我不知道该粘贴到哪啊
Tasha: Actually, I don't know where to paste it
Tasha: 粘贴到
Tasha: Paste it to
Jake:yes
Jake: Yes
Tasha: 好了吗
Tasha: Is it done?
Jake:试试喽
Jake: Try it out
Shure: 我是2了吧唧
Shure: I'm such an idiot
Jake:什么东西哈哈哈
Jake: What are you talking about, hahaha
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Shure: 哈你告诉AI一
Shure: Haha, you tell the AI
Shure: 些人类记密码的方式
Shure: some ways humans remember passwords
Tasha: 你打开了吗哦哦哦
Tasha: Did you open it? Oh oh oh
Shure: 叫什么吧
Shure: What's it called?
Jake:你登一Google看一下啊
Jake: Log into Google and check it out
Shure: 可能吧
Shure: Maybe
Alice:好嘞好嘞
Alice: Alright, alright
Alice:我吗我吗
Alice: Me? Me?
Shure: 哈哈我可以变成女童吗
Shure: Haha, can I become a girl?
Jake:啊是我吗
Jake: Oh, is it me?
Alice:是我吗
Alice: Is it me?
Shure: 我先trance一下
Shure: I'll trans first
Alice:我登Google看一下对是
Alice: Let me log into Google and check, yes
Shure: 然后再let me一下
Shure: And then let me
Jake:对是
Jake: Yes, it is
Shure: 那我跟不trance的意见有什么区别
Shure: What's the difference between my opinion and non-trans opinion?
Shure: 哦懂了
Shure: Oh, I get it
Shure: 给你安排一张是吧
Shure: You're setting up a card, right?
其他人：不不不
Others: No no no
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Jake:因为里边太乱了
Jake: Because it's too messy inside
Jake:其实可以变得比较干净
Jake: Actually, it can be pretty clean.
Jake:但是收视的时候要戴眼镜所以
Jake: But when watching TV, you have to wear glasses, so...
Jake:延迟了一会
Jake: It got delayed for a bit.
Shure: 今天按按您的要求点了两份炒蛋
Shure: Today, as per your request, I ordered two servings of scrambled eggs.
Lucia: 啊哈哈笑了
Lucia: Ahaha, laughed.
Lucia: 我觉得我这个好像
Lucia: I think mine seems like...
Jake:对是呃
Jake: Yes, it is, uh...
Jake:你要先打开新民主的那个小
Jake: 完喽再请坐
Jake: After the rocket is done, please take a seat.
Shure: 就是把自己打个码
Shure: It's like censoring yourself.
Lucia: 打开他的打开他的
Alice:把他的换成别人的
Jake:就是这个
Jake:之后这边加哎就上来
Shure: using name和密码是
Shure: Using the name and password is...
Jake:对呃然后你刚刚复制了吗那个东西
Jake: Yes, uh, did you just copy that thing?
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: And then...
Jake:那就把这个给换掉
Jake: Then replace this.
Lucia: 嗯到期了吗
Lucia: Hmm, is it expired?
Jake:对七天七天过去了
Jake: Yes, seven days have passed.
Shure: 啊你说这个登录到期了
Shure: Ah, you mean the login expired?
Jake:呃对是吧
Jake: Uh, yes, right?
Jake:对对他少俩人吗
Jake: Yes, yes, he is missing two people, right?
Alice:他少俩人吗
Alice: He's missing two people?
Alice:你去喊一下吧去吧
Alice: You go call them, go ahead.